[Musique]
Frédéri lurol bonjour vous êtes la
directrice du château de montchistau là
on on va parler évidemment de de
l'histoire de ce château mais là on se
trouve dans un une des pièces
emblématiques de ce château qui est le
salon moresque alors pourquoi d'abord il
y a un salon moresque dans ce château
alors Duma était un grand voyageur et en
1846 il lui a été demandé d'aller
voyager en Orient afin de ramener de son
voyage ses impressions de voyage qu'il
publiait sous forme de feuilleton dans
la presse et le gouvernement lui a
demandé d'aller en Orient afin de
pousser les Français à aller s'installer
dans les nouvelles colonies français
alors Duma s'en va il y va et là-bas il
tombe littéralement amoureux de de
l'architecture mort et il est témoin de
la réalisation du mausolée du BA de
Tunis et là il est enchanté et il veut
absolument ramener avec lui les deux
artisans qui sont en train de sculpter
le mausolé pour le faire construire
voilà pour faire construire un salon
moresque chez lui au château de monteé
Cristo et il a il a demandé au B Tunis
de l' ramené le bêuni c'était pas tout à
fait d'accord au démarrage mais Dumain
lui a donné un argument de poids il lui
a dit mais vous faites une œuvre de mort
vous n'êtes donc pas pressé moi je veux
une œuvre de vie c'est génial et donc il
il ramène les les les
artisans il construit ce salon qui a été
alors il faut dire qui a été rénové il y
a pas si longtemps que ça alors en 1985
le château souffrait beaucoup de
l'humidité et le salon moresque
souffrait étonnamment il y avait des é
était au milieu de la pièce et grâce au
messénat du roi Hassan 2 deux artisans
marocains sont venus ici pour restaurer
ce salon dans les règles de l'art dans
les règles de l'art ça veut dire dans
dans le même décor que que celui qui
avait voulu qui avait voulu Alexandre
Duma alors on va revenir sur sur
l'histoire de de de de ce château euh
alors d vivait je crois pas très loin il
vivait à Saint-Germain à l'époque et
puis il découvre ce domaine d'abord oui
Duma au départ habite Paris mais vou
être plus tranquille quoi il voulait
être plus tranquille il s'éloigne il va
à Saint-Germain en lait mais à
Saint-Germain c'est exactement la même
chose il il s'investit dans la vie local
il s'occupe du théâtre local il y a
toujours beaucoup de gens qui sont
autour de lui il a besoin de
concentration pour écrire et un jour
alors qu'il marche entre Saint-Germain
en lait et Versailles il tombe amoureux
encore une fois parce que Duma est un
homme un peu toutff toutou femme oui
exactement c'était vrai avec les femmes
mais c'était vrai avec lieux quoi tout à
fait et il voit ces terrains qui donne
une vue sur la scne à l'époque euh il
achète différents terrains auprès de de
différents paysans h et ensuite il fait
venirou parce que c'est la campagne ah
c'est la campagne oui oui il n'y a plus
rien il n'y a plus rien aujourd'hui de
cette campagne là parce que alors nous
sommes toujours dans un environnement
très très boisé mais il y a quand même
beaucoup de routes aujourd'hui il y a
une urbanisation importante qui
n'existait pas à l'époque bien entendu
euh mais Duma demande à un architecte
qui s'appelle Hippolyte Duran de venir
lui construire sa maison de campagne
alors c'est un projet de maison de
campagne qui s'est un petit peu été pe
étofé oui et puis c'est devenu ce
château on est en quoi
1840 1844 44 donc il a un peu plus de 40
ans en gros hein et il a déjà eu des
succès il a écrit il a déjà écrit Les
trois mousquetaires il a écrit le compte
de monteé Cristo donc il est riche enfin
voilà il vit bien il a eu un début de
vie plus compliqué mais là il là il
est très populaire très riche il veut
que ça se sache il veut que ça se voit
et avoir une belle maison mais pour lui
permet de de de montrer c'est un peu
auantatoire quand même alors on va
parler de la maison et au fait il y a
deux endroits enfin il y a cette maison
et puis il y a un bureau qui va se faire
construire qui est un peu à l'écart oui
en même temps qu'il commande ce cette
maison à son architecte il veut
également un cabinet de travail dans
lequel il pourra s'isoler pour écrire
alors ce cabinet de travail c'est un
petit cabinet
néogothique avec un balcon en bois
àjouré qui peut faire penser à un chalet
suisse il y a aussi un un donjon avec
des des parties normandes c'est assez
étonnant c'est très éclectique au niveau
de de l'architecture et en plus de ça il
veut être isolé et il demande à ce qu'il
y ait des bassins et queil y ait un
bassin qui entoure ce château diif on ne
peut y accéder qu'en empruntant un petit
pont de pierre ah d'accord ou il pour
être pour être sur d' tranquille il a
son bureau qui donne sur le château F
oui il a toujours cette magnifique vue
puisque c'est ce qu'il avait séduit
lorsqu'il avait vu les terrains donc
depuis son bureau il peut voir le le
chat de Monte Cristo alors puisque vous
parliez d'architecture et de de
l'architecte Hippolyte Duran euh comment
comment on pourrait qualifier
l'architecture de ce château parce que
ça mêle beaucoup de choses quand même
oui alors ce château est sculpté de
toutes parts euh il présente deux
clochetons qui qui sont magnifiques avec
surmonté d'un toit en zingue et en plomb
c'est une maison style Renaissance c'est
Renaissance c'est baroque c'est il il y
a un peu de de mélange il y a des
sculptures alors ça il demande quoi des
des des décorateurs de théâtre c'est ça
de faire des oui il demande à des
décorateurs de théâtre de venir décorer
les façades de son château et ce qui est
le plus surprenant et le plus touchant à
la fois c'est que au-dessus des
premières fenêtres du rez-de-chaussée il
y a des visages d'écrivain qui étaient
cher à Duma donc on va trouver on va
trouver Shakespeare
Châteaubriant Virgile voilà des des
auteurs qui qui l'aimit des auteur qui
était ses maîtres enfin en quelque sorte
euh évidemment c'est c'est on dit disait
il avait un gros cœur qu'il aimait
beaucoup les il aimait beaucoup les
femmes il aimait beaucoup les lieux il
aimait beaucoup aussi manger ah oui et
et il a fait d'ailleurs des des des
livres de recettes de de de cuisine qui
sont qui ont été republiés enfin qui
sont assez formidables il recevait
beaucoup ici il recevait il recevait
beaucoup on dit que lors de sa pandaison
de crémaillère il avait envoyé une
cinquantaine d'invitations et sont 600
personnes qui se sont présentées ici
afin de découvrir les lieux et de de
pouvoir profiter
profiter de la présence de de cet auteur
qui qui était extrêmement populaire et
c'est vrai que sa générosité était était
connue de tous c'est lui qui faisait la
cuisine ici ou il avait non il avait un
personnel quand même il y avait du
personnel mais il lui arrivait de faire
la cuisine et de concocter lui-même les
menus c'est une pièce importante la
cuisine ça l'était sans doute à l'époque
malheureusement elle a totalement
disparu aujourd'hui ouou alors donc on
est en 1844 quand il fait construire
cette cette maison elle va être finie à
peu près
quand ensite la date qui est inscrite
sur le château c'est
1846 a priori voilà a priori la maison
est terminée en 1846 la pandaison de
crémaillère se fait en 1847 h h et puis
malheureusement il est suiv oui ça va
très vite parce que il est poursuivi par
ses créanciers et en 1848 il se doit de
vendre tout le mobilier qui était
présent dans le château et il faut
imaginer un mobilier considérable avec
beaucoup de teintures de tapis de
meubles de toutes sortes de tout e
époque beaucoup d'objets enfin c'était
vraiment très très chargé des tableaux
aussi et il vend tout en 1848 il vend la
maison en 1849 parce qu'il est vraiment
poursuivi mais il continue à vivre un
petit peu he il arrive à il y a un prêon
enfin il a une histoire un peu un peu un
peu louche enfin un peu louche c'est am
on va se débrouiller voilà parce que oui
probablement qu'il aime cette maison
qu'il a pas envie malgré malgré ses
difficultés financières de la quitter
quoi exactement dum disait de cette
maison qu'il avait ici une réduction du
paradis terrestre donc ça montre un
petit peu l'attachement qui qu'il avait
à ce lieu et puis euh bon donc un ami
achète achète la maison le terrain et le
le cabinet de travail euh mais pas
beaucoup per mais pas très cher par
rapport à ce que ça a coûté enfin
exactement exactement oui c'est pas une
bonne affaire enfin de toute façon quoi
qu'il arrive même si c'est il avait
coutume de dire que un jour il avait il
il voit un ami il lui dit tu vois ces
deux prunes c'est tout ce qui reste de
de mon château ah c'est terrible il va
être obligé de quitter hein oui en 51 on
sait qu'il est qu'il est définitivement
parti puisqu'il est parti s'installer en
Belgique h donc alors euh il va avoir
une histoire un peu un peu triste enfin
de de d'abord la maison est rachetée par
des gens plutôt aisés euh oui la maison
est rachetée il y a différents
propriétaires qui se succède et puis là
on arrive au 20e siècle la maison
commence à appartenir à une siété
immobilière qui va louer les lieux alors
il faut imaginer des gens qui sont
locataires qui entretiennent comme ils
peuvent on fait quoi des appartements
non ça reste une maison quand même mais
c'est vrai que l'entretien est est moins
bon le propriétaire la société
immobilière n'entretient pas exactement
comme il faudrait malheureusement ce qui
fait que les lieux se dégradent et on
arrive en
1969 le château est en piteuse état
toutes les façades sont entièrement
noirci de l'eau s'infiltre par les
toitures le parc est dans un état
ou ça pousse partout quoi exactement
exactement et euh le la société
immobilière décide de tout raser pour
construire un ensemble de 400 logement
ou euh il propose même le le projet à la
préfecture et ça failli être accepté par
la préfecture ce qui est paraît fou
aujourd'hui et heureusement il y a une
levée de bouclier de plusieurs
institutions différentes et notamment
dans l'in deco non alors voilà l'un deco
a créé la société des Amis d'Alexandre
Duar il a fait un appel puisque il a
profité de sa popularité oui ça il était
il était très populaire exactement il il
a écrit un articleoui il adorait
Alexandre Dubar évidemment il avait un
bon de compteur d'ailleurs qui ressemble
un peu à à ce qu'aurait pu être
Alexandre dum s'il avait fait de la de
la radio de la télévision mais mais et
et et on va finir par oui arrivver à
sauver cette cette maison quoi la maison
est sauvée parce que les trois villes de
marliy loi le port marli et le PEC qui
sont les trois villes qui qui sont là
autour du du château se sont cindés ont
créé un syndicat intercommunal et ce
indndicat intercommunal a acheté les
lieux ce qu'il vous on directrices ce
qui a ce qui a aidé qui aidé un peu plus
tard ce qui a aidé à la Servie du
château je je je parle de ça parce que
évidemment faut il faut dire que on peut
venir évidemment visiter euh ce château
on peut venir tout seul on peut il y a
aussi des visites guidées et puis il y a
il y a alors là il suffit de se
renseigner hein puis on a un site
internet on peut nous téléphoner aussi
sur notre site internet tout est indiqué
nous faisons des visites guidées des
visites guidées théattralisées nous
organisons des journées particulières
cette année en en juin nous organisons
une journée romantique un salon du livre
jeunesse en octobre et puis nous avons
des
expositions oui exactement on en aura
une de juin septembre avec les œufres
d'un artiste qui s'appelle Bruno Lemé et
qui sculpte le fer et le bois flotté
donc c'est dans tout le jardin les les
œubrres on peut admirer les uvres en
même temps qu'on vient euh visiter le le
château et évidemment tout ça coûte cher
euh malure ou oui oui et et et et et là
il y a des besoins de rénovation là
actuellement nous avons besoin de
beaucoup d'argent puisqu'il faut créer
un drainage périphérique autour du
château pour éviter que l'eau continue à
remonter par capillarité de no pièces
pour éviter que le salpêtre ne
s'installe dans les caves c'est déjà ça
commence à être le cas il faut que nous
fassions aussi toute une campagne de
révision de toutes les menuiseries du du
château puisque les fenêtres sont
d'origine et il faut à tout prix les
préserver euh on a des problèmes sur la
la toiture également il faut installer
un part il y a beaucoup chir un appel
voilà nous avons ouvert oui nous avons
ouvert une souscription publique auprès
de la Fondation du Patrimoine et nous
invitons chacun à nous aider à restaurer
ce lieu à le préserver puis à pouvoir le
le léguer aux générations futures parce
que c'est c'est important c'est un au
lieu du patrimoine français c'est un
lieu de la culture française si on veut
se renseigner on peut aller sur le site
c'est indiqué tout à fait sur notre site
internet donc château tir Moné
cristo.com très bien écoutez je vous
remercie beaucoup Frédéric lurol de nous
avoir fait visiter un peu ce château
j'espère qu'on a donné l'envie aux gens
de venir peut-être de souscrire un peu
puis d'aider d'aider d'aider ce ce ce
château en tout cas voilà c'est tout
près de Paris on on n pas dit qu'on
était à marllereroi on est au port Marl
exactement ce qui est juste à côté de
marloi à 20 km de Paris voilà donc vous
avez bien fait de le dire parce que
j'avais dit une bêtise merci infiniment
je vous en prie merci à
vous
[Musique]
fore